look at this guy look at this guy look  at this look at this it appeared that he  was doing stunts on the freeway right  now really just kind of showing off you  know yeah we don't want to encourage  this but do we also don't want to miss  anything that might happen out here you  know this is our job to document and  watch and basically inform the public  again got a lot of traffic out here he's  bright going right up the center he's  got two officers from the California  Highway Patrol the two motorcycle  officers from earlier on  here you can see I'm that he basically  just is is complying now just out of the  blue decided to stop right here at a gas  station maybe he was running roll out  low on fuel were you afraid for other  people's lives what do you mean you  didn't endanger anybody you're standing  on your bike going a hundred miles per  hour I just want to say that I love my  family and my two baby girls and I'm  sorry I disappointed them in the middle  of all this